(applause)
Now, Jason, congratulations,
of course you're getting
a lot of attention
for your Joe Biden impression
on Saturday Night Live.
Thank you, thank you very much.
Did you always do a Joe Biden
For years.
When you were a kid?
How did you have to
work on this impression?
Literally, we did one last year
for the Halloween shows him
dressed up for something.
And so I just did three lines
and then over the summer
when he was named the
vice president nominee,
I remembered that I was doing Joe Biden.
That I had done him
because I got a text
from people at the show
saying "Hey, congrats".
I was like, "congrats"?
Why?
Oh, oh right, I do Joe Biden.
Sure.
So then, I watched a lot of YouTube
throughout this last week to sort of
try to study him.
It's all the teeth.
It's all teeth.
Like, I don't have Joe Biden teeth.
Like, when I smile.
Like, if I just smile normally.
You know, it's all gums.
You get a lot of gum, yeah.
No teeth whatsoever.
So then they were very nice.
I even brought them with me
cause I carry them all the time.
I ride with them on the subway.
But look at this right here.
There they are.
(Conan and audience laughs and applauds)
There he is.
(applause)
Those are overpowering.
I know.
Turn those off.
There he is.
Look at that.
Oh, man.
You get this to show
up on a wide angle too.
Look at that, hey!
Those are beautiful, yeah.
Not bad, right?
Now, did you get a lot of
feedback on that sketch?
I did, yeah.
You know, we just watched
a little clip of it.
Yeah, I mean, from like
friends out of nowhere.
Most of it positive.
I did however get one guy
that was a little upset at me.
I actually have it here on MySpace.
Everybody has MySpace, right?
You know MySpace.
Right.
People can get ahold of ya.
and let you know their feelings.
What was it that bothered him?
It was the run there about
Scranton, Pennsylvania.
About it being a jerk wad of a town.
Is he from Scranton?
Yeah, I'm guessing that's where he's from.
His name's Pete.
This is real.
This really happened.
The subject was "Eat me".
(audience laughs)
And then this is what he says:
"If you have a problem with Scranton,
why don't you come out
and say it to my face,
you (bleep) no-talent hack".
Fair hit.
Yeah.
I get a lot of these.
Yeah, I believe it.
"It's funny that I had
to see the Scranton skit
on the Internet since I thought
SNL was canceled years ago.
Turns out, it's still on.
It just sucks.
(audience laughs)
Why don't you take a long
swim in the East river?
Before you do, be sure to strap
200 lbs of bricks on your
back before you jump in".
But then it signs off
(bleeps) bite me you (bleep).
(audience laughs)
There's Pete right there.
There's Pete.
Let's see Pete.
Look at that.
(audience laughs and applauds)
Nice looking guy!
I love how, like he wrote that (growls).
Then it's like time for
a photo to go with that.
Oh, okay.
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna put on my best duds.
Yeah.
I mean, he looks like a really nice guy.
And I can't bolt him for loving his town.
I mean, obviously, I do want to say
Pete, in all sincerity,
I've never been to Scranton,
but I respect the fact that you like it
and I'm sorry for
upsetting you in any way.
I actually did not write that.
The writer that did,
here's his email address.
It's ScrantonSucksBigOne
(silence)
(audience laughs)
That's the best way.
Just go right to him.
(audience applauds and cheers)
His name's Petey.
Now, of course Tina Fey
getting a lot of attention
for her governor panel, which
is a great governor panel.
Absolutely, no, I mean,
she needs the dough.
She had a comeback and
needed it, you know.
She was desperate for that part.
Didn't even look anything
like her, but it's sad.
No, it's fantastic.
It's such a buzzsaw as they
stay in sports to be up there.
It's so nerve-wracking.
I was like, she's so great at it
and looks just like her
and sounds just like her
and it's such a fun take on her.
And I was like oh, I
hope that this doesn't go
as I'm thinking it might
where she says stuff and everybody laughs
and then I say stuff,
nobody says anything.
Not even looking at me.
Just waiting for her to
talk again or something.
It would be awful.
People love the teeth.
They love the teeth.
Now, I'm curious about something.
When I worked Saturday
Night Live years ago,
one of the best things
is all the cool people
that would show up to do it.
Here you are, you guys are
satirizing the presidential campaign
and these people actually show up.
Have you gotten a chance to really meet
or get to know Barack
Obama or John McCain?
I don't know if I got to
know them, necessarily.
I mean, I get it, I get it. I get it.
After you said that meant
"It's okay, I got it".
I get it.
No, no, no it's all right.
I met Barack Obama that same sketch
where I was dressed as Joe Biden.
We met him.
They're a real nice guy.
Good eye contact.
Good handshake.
Looks good in a suit.
Yep.
Check.
Exactly.
I got it.
All three boxes checked.
And then John McCain was on last year.
And in between the dress show
which we do before the live show,
there's a meeting in Lauren's' office.
And it's like 50 of us all sitting around.
You may remember this.
In a tiny room.
People are all like squeezed in.
I sit on a stair,
like on a step like this down here.
Really copping a squat.
Literally it looks like
I'm about to take a dump.
(audience laughs) You
know what I mean right?
Why, why?
That's just the position I'm in.
Yes, okay thanks.
But it's only funny because
at this point, John
McCain comes walking over
cause there's an empty
spot right next to me.
Sits right down next to me.
Like, we're like two
little kids with our knees
like right by our chin.
And I'm wearing KU basketball shorts.
Kansas University basketball shorts,
which I wear in-between the shows
just because it's comfortable.
And he starts talking
to me about you know,
Kansas basketball and
like, Arizona basketball
and Luke Olsen, I think
was their coach there.
And all this stuff.
Anyway, we're talking while Lauren
is giving our bosses, is giving us notes,
trying to tell us the changes
that are about to happen to the live show.
Lauren can be intimidating
in this meeting.
Oh, extremely intimidating.
He's making quick changes
30 minutes before this
thing's about to go out
to millions and millions of people.
And John McCain is just like
"How about the KU Jayhawks and Luke Olsen"
and I'm like we're gonna get busted.
Like, you can't.
We're supposed to be
paying attention, sir.
But then I realized I'm
not gonna get in trouble.
Lauren's not gonna yell at John McCain.
I'm in the clear. I was
like, do you want to share
what you're talking about
to the rest of the class?
I was like, we're talking
about foreign policy.
Leave us alone.
Don't worry about it.
We're figuring it out.
Worry about your silly skits.
[Conan] Now, I wish I
had been there for that.